لاحتمال الموت للديكتاتور،
متظاهر يمزق ملصقًا
للمرشد الأعلى الإيراني
[تصفيق]
قُتلت فتاة صغيرة بسبب
الحجاب الإلزامي، لم نتمكن من تحمله بعد الآن،
كان الأمر أشبه بنار مختبئة تحت
الرماد
ومثل حريق  انتشرت النيران الهائلة للاحتجاجات
في كل ركن من أركان إيران، وقد
قوبل غضبهم بالقمع العنيف
في بلدة إسرائيلية صغيرة، حيث أظهر الخوف من الفوضى التي
تم التقاطها في فيديو الهاتف الخليوي المهتز
قوات الأمن وهي
تفتح النار على المتظاهرين،
وهو مشهد يصعب مشاهدته
هرع الحشد لمساعدة امرأة تصرخ من الألم
بعد أن أصيبت برصاصة في عينها،
تلك اللحظة التي أُصبت فيها بالرصاص كانت
أسوأ لحظة في حياتي
[موسيقى]
مع توأمها البالغ من العمر عشر سنوات
كان أطفالي يصرخون
قتلت والدتنا عندما بدأ هذا الشخص في
إطلاق النار رأيناه على بعد 30 أو
40 مترًا ورأيته يستهدفنا،
استدرت جانبًا لحماية أطفالي وتم
إطلاق النار علي كما لو كان الدم الوحيد الذي
غطيت عيني بيدي شعرت به
وكأنني لو رفعت يدي فقد تسقط
من مأخذها.
ليس الناشط الوحيد الذي يقول إن
قوات الأمن الإيرانية كانت تستخدم المنصات المعدنية
والرصاص المطاطي بشكل متعمد
ومنهجي، مما أدى إلى إصابة
أكثر من 500 متظاهر بالعمى،
وفقًا لمجموعات حقوق الإنسان، وقد
شارك العديد منهم صورهم.  على الإنترنت لكن
الأنظمة وصفتهم بالكاذبين الذين ينشرون
الدعاية
[الموسيقى]
في المستشفى في هذا الألم المؤلم
لساعات يتردد الأطباء في مساعدتها بينما
كانت قوات الأمن تطارد
المصابين ومن ساعدهم
بعد إجراء عملية جراحية لعلاج جرحها،
بقي في منزلهم  غرفة مظلمة لأكثر من
ثلاثة أسابيع كنت
أسمعهم من غرفتي وهم يرددون
شعارات كان هناك شيء يسحبني إلى الخارج لأتحدث وأصرخ
للمطالبة بحقوقي
شعرت أن معركتي لم تنته بعد
لكنها أرادت أيضًا إنقاذ عينها مع
بمساعدة الصحفية الإيطالية إيلاجي،
تمكنت من الوصول إلى إيطاليا حيث خضعت
لمزيد من العمليات الجراحية. اكتشف الأطباء بعد فوات الأوان
أن الحنك الذي كان لا يزال موجودًا
خلف عينها قد تحرك واضطروا
إلى إزالة العين التي تم تزويدها
بطرف صناعي، لكن الحياة لم تكن
أصعب من أي وقت مضى  من أجل إلهي، فهي لا تزال تعيش مع
الألم الجسدي والصدمة بمفردها في
بلد أجنبي وتعتمد الآن على التبرعات
والأصدقاء للبقاء على قيد الحياة والأصعب من ذلك
كله أنها لا تعرف ما إذا كانت سترى
أطفالها مرة أخرى أم لا.
لم أندم أبدًا على هذا ولن أندم أبدًا
إذا عدت إلى  إيران سأفعل ذلك مرة أخرى،
يقول الكثيرون إن هذه الثورة قد انتهت لكنها
لم تنته في
جميع أنحاء البلاد، تخرج النساء الآن
بدون حجاب لأنهن
لم يعدن خائفات منهن، هذه هي
طريقتنا في المقاومة المدنية
ربما يكون النظام قد سحقها  احتجاجات
لكن صمود إيلي مثل كثيرين
آخرين لا يتزعزع
بغض النظر عن عدد المرات التي قطعوا فيها
الزهور، فهم لا يستطيعون منع الربيع من القدوم، لقد
أطلقوا النار على عيني وأطلقوا النار على الآخرين،
لكن النضال مستمر بغض النظر عن
عدد الأشخاص الذين قتلوا، فلن يتمكنوا من ذلك.  أوقفوا قدوم
الربيع، فلا يمكنهم منع
الحرية من العودة إلينا.
سي إن إن ميلان إيطاليا